our next speaker is
thanks for inviting me
um good afternoon everyone uh thanks for
stopping by my talk so I'm going to talk
about reinforcement learning
um and this is Joint work with uh my
former student xivision who is currently
postdoc at Caltech
um and Xavier is not here right now I
don't know if he's watching online but
uh he's going to be here starting
tomorrow he'll be at the workshop next
week and Xavier and I are going to
connect a joint tutorial on Monday at
the uh at the workshop
um and the tutorial relates to some of
what I'm going to talk about today and
I'll point out as we call up so I guess
I don't need to really introduce
reinforcement learning there's so many
success stories I think every year will
be a new nature paper about success of
reinforcement learning and one new
application starting from alphago to
protein folding navigation uh
manipulating robotic arm manipulating
plasma uh in a collider and so on and at
the heart of for a reinforcement
learning problem is modeled by what is
called as an mdp markup decision process
so I'm trying to give a very quick
overview a three-minute overview of
introduction of reinforcement learning
before I jump into my results so there's
typically an agent and there's an
environment which represents the state
around the agent and the agent interacts
with this environment by taking an
action at each time and the environment
responds in two ways one is that it
moves to a new state and it gives a
reward and the goal of the agent is to
maximize long-term rewards and this is a
classical markovation process model
which is used extensively in various
engineering problems the main difference
in reinforcement learning is that the
transition probabilities the
probabilities of next state and reward
given the current state and action are
unknown so you have to learn them as you
go along or more precisely you actually
don't care about the transition
probabilities as such you want to learn
the policy that maximizes the long-term
reward and by policy what I mean is that
a mapping everything time you go to a
state you take a particular action or
you sample actions from a particular
distribution and that's given by the
policy
so typically to do anything with
reinforcement learning you need to we
need to work with value function and
there's something called The V function
which is uh used in classic mdp Theory
which is simply the long term total
reward and I'm working in the infinite
Horizon discounted cost setting so if I
sum all the rewards will go to Infinity
so I discount them with the inflation
Factor gamma and so if I start in state
s and follow a given policy Pi I take
actions at every time from this policy
and I look at the long term reward
that's uh uh that's denoted by VPS and I
can tabulate all of these in a vector
for different starting States and it's
my value function uh there's something
called The Q function which is used in
reinforcement learning are not classical
mdps and I'll explain why in the next
slide uh it's defined analogously except
that my starting state is my starting
action is a at time 0 I don't follow the
policy I just take my action a and after
that I follow the policy and this is
defined as a function of S and A so this
is a bigger Vector the size of this
Vector is s dimensional the size of this
Vector is s times C I am working with
finite State and action spaces so even
though these are functions for me they
are just vectors because this can only
take finite values and it can take
finite values
the goal is to find the policy that
maximizes this V Pi uh this is a vector
what do I mean by maximizing the vector
it turns out there is a policy that
maximizes all the components
simultaneously and that's what I'm
interested in
typically to do this sometimes people
think of a smaller goal which is given a
policy Pi uh I want to find the
corresponding value function either we
function of the Q function depending on
the setting and that's usually called
the policy evaluation problem
now um
so for the policy evaluation problem
um uh I want to find V Pi for a given
pie and turns out V Pi solves this
equation you don't have to pass this
equation the only thing I want you to
understand about this equation is that V
Pi shows on the left shows up on the
left hand side and the right hand side
and there's some complicated expression
here which involves the expectation so
the whole thing is linear and this
expectation involves the transition
probabilities I don't know which means I
have to solve this fixed Point equation
when I don't know this operator
and similarly to if I want to solve the
control problem then one way of doing it
is to find the the value function
corresponding to the optimal policy uh
so here I'm illustrating it with me here
I'm using q q star is the value function
of the optimal policy and it satisfies a
Bellman equation that looks like this
which is very similar except that
there's a Max here and because of that
it becomes a non-linear equation and
this is again yet another fixed Point
equation
um and the reason I care about this
optimal value function is because if if
I can find this Q star then my goal is
to find the optimal policy remember then
I can simply take the Q star and do the
ARG Max for each for each state I do ARG
Max over actions and that will give me
the optimal policy so finding Q star is
as good as finding optimal policy
okay good so uh reinforcement learning
is essentially uh solving either for
this or sometimes the policy evaluation
problem when you don't know the
underlying operator and
um uh so there are two if it's again
step back from reinforcement learning
and go to mdps uh the two approaches
that people use value iteration and
policy iteration but before I talk about
that any questions with the setup so far
okay but so uh I'll not talk about value
iteration too much where I might in a
bit but uh I'll focus on policy
iteration in this talk in policy
iteration it's a two-step process it's
an iterative process where there are two
steps in each iteration the first step
is to do policy evaluation so you start
with the initial policy pi and at every
time
you keep iterating through a sequence of
policies at every time when you have a
policy you evaluate it which means you
find the corresponding value function
either we function or Q function
depending on the context in RL will work
with Q function and
um uh and then once you have the queue
function or the V function of the
corresponding policy you do policy
Improvement uh by going to a next policy
which is better and to do this if you
had V function to find this better
policy would involve knowledge of the
underlying model which we don't have
that's the reason in RL we work with the
queue function so that if I just do ARG
Max among the actions then I would get
the next policy
now how do I do policy evaluation policy
evaluation remember just reduces to
solving the a fixed Point equation for
the value function and that can be done
using something called value iteration
where you just keep applying the
operator again and again till you
coverage so this is the high level
scheme uh so there are value uh there
are methods in RL focused on valuation
I'll not talk about them today I'll talk
about them on Monday at the workshop uh
but today I want to focus on policy
iteration and if I want to uh adopt this
approach in reinforcement learning what
we get are called actor critic methods
so instead of policy uh iteration we
call it actor critic the idea is that I
have to iterate through these policies
without knowing the model so I have to
sample from the environment and the
policy evaluation is done by the
critique and uh in uh now the critique
uses something called TD learning to or
its variance to evaluate the policy
instead of value iteration because we
don't know the underlying operator and
instead of policy the policy Improvement
is done by actor and um the problem
there is one challenge here so if you
want TD learning to work it will work
only if you explore all the state action
spaces uh uh States and actions so even
if we forget about all the details the
idea is that if you want to find the
optimal policy you should at least check
out all the states and actions otherwise
it doesn't make sense that you can find
the optimal policy and for that to
happen you want your policies to be
exploratory enough you don't want your
policies to be deterministic you want
them to be uh randomized policies at
every time so if you do ARG Max you will
end up with a deterministic policy like
in one step and that's too bad so people
do variants of this Arc Max and that
leads to various algorithms called
policy gradient National policy gradient
and so on and let's look at this in more
detail so what I'm going to do in the
rest of the talk is I'll spend the next
several minutes talking about the actor
and we'll present our results on the
actor after that I'll talk about the
critique then I'll put everything
together and present the results for
active critic this is what is coming up
questions
so I said that uh in mdps for policy
Improvement one simply does ARG Max and
I don't want a deterministic policies
policy I want a stochastic policy so a
national thing would be to approximate
it by a soft Max and we have already
encountered softmax this morning
um and uh softmax uh I'm not writing it
exactly I'm just saying proportional to
and this parameter beta can can be
thought of as a tunable parameter which
I'm going to tune eventually and if beta
is very very large then this soft match
essentially becomes art Max uh and the
Spy will become ones and zeros
so in fact this can be thought of as
some kind of approximate policy
iteration and the results in our paper
and the results I'm going to show are
also applicable to the setting but in
this talk I don't want to focus on this
instead I want to focus on this so what
I do is I take the current policy I use
I use the current policy also while
doing the arguments so somehow I
multiply the current policy with this
with this exponentiation this is also
yet another approximation to do policy
Improvement and this algorithm is called
what is is called the natural policy
gradient so I am introducing it as some
kind of weird approximation of policy
Improvement but the many many
interpretations of this uh one is what I
just talked about the second
interpretation is it can be thought of
as mirror descent generalized to
reinforcement learning mirror detention
optimization generalized to
reinforcement learning and mirror
descent when you have a Simplex
constraint can be written in terms of
multiplicative weight update form this
is the weight update form and we talked
about pre-conditioning this morning and
this can also be interpreted as simply
doing gradient descent with a feature
information preconditionally
um and this can also be thought of as
regular mdps the many many
interpretations of this
um I think initially when it was
introduced by uh Sham kakade in 20 2002
20 years ago he actually thought of it
as preconditioning
okay so the result I want to state in
this context uh is that this is the
first result uh that I'm stating is that
um under appropriate choice of steps as
I'll come back to this the
um uh so I'm only thinking of the actor
for the time being I am not worrying
about the critic because to actually
implement this I need to evaluate Q by K
for them for the next few minutes let's
pretend that a genie gives me this qpi K
exactly but eventually I have to uh I
have to estimate it then if I run this
update I have the following convergence
Q star so here I actually don't even
care about Q I care about the policy the
policy after capital K iterations is my
Pi K and I'm saying that's good good in
what sense if I look at its value
function and compare it to the optimal
value function uh then the difference of
that is going to Decay geometrically
fast there are two terms uh sorry this
is wrong this should be Q by zero this
is Q by zero this is a typo so this week
is geometrically fast gamma is my
discount factor which is less than on
the second term also is because
geometrically fast
Now what is my Beta beta K it doesn't
depend on any unknown in the system the
only thing it uses is the current policy
uh the policy uh the this is like a
matrix for every state and action you
have a number for every uh for every
state
um
so you have to minimize over one uh
uh sorry for every state find the action
that minimizes the current value
function that is this guy and then look
at the small minimize this over all the
uh States
um but whatever this is this is just a
function of the current policy and the
main thing I want to highlight here is
that the step size is actually
increasing gamma power K gamma per K is
decreasing within the denominator so
it's increasing so even though you can
think of it as an optimization uh
algorithm like mirror descent and so on
this is a very counterintuitive in
optimization you never increase step
sizes you either make it keep them
constant or you decrease them
it's a way exactly exactly so if you
correct if that's the reason I
introduced it this way once you look at
it this way it's very clear that beta
should increase so the time my
approximation in the maximization is
becoming better and better but if you
take the mirror distance Viewpoint the
beta is going to be the step size and
there it's uh it's a puzzle as to why
you would increase instead of decrease
good and uh very quick overview of
related work
um natural policy gradient like I said
was introduced by Kaka day 20 years ago
and three years ago agarwale town uh
essentially presented the first proof of
convergence uh to the global Optimum and
they showed a rate of 1 over K and they
take the Mirror Mirror decent Viewpoint
and work with KL Divergence as a lapino
function
um and one of the surprising result uh
this is a breakthrough paper in the
space and there is a reason being that
before them it was not clear if this
policy Improvement methods even
converged to the global Optimum and they
showed that it converges they do
Converse to the global Optimum even
though the corresponding objective here
turns out to be non-convex and they got
a rate of 1 over K and there is some
follow-up work where people showed I
mean these papers are actually two years
old these are the
accepted Journal versions but they first
came out two years ago
um uh these two papers show geometric
convergence but once their regular is
the objective uh by adding a regular
razor you speed up the rate of
conversions from one of our K to
geometric geometric uh is also called
linear convergence and optimization
literature and they still uh exploit the
mirror distant Viewpoint what uh the
main message I'm trying to convey in
this part of the talk is that you don't
need geometric you don't need
regularization even without
regularization even though your
objective is non-con non-convex you will
have geometric convergence and the
reason is that convexity and
optimization Viewpoint is not the right
way of thinking about it this problem is
not a random convex optimization a
random non-con non-convex optimization
problem it's actually the there's this
nice Bellman operator sitting at the
heart of this problem which has
contractive and other nice properties
and because of that we get geometric
geometric contract geometric convergence
so our proof essentially goes back to
the mdp literature on approximate policy
iteration and we exploit contraction and
monotonicity properties of bellman
operator as opposed to worrying about
convexity
um and uh I'm focusing on one particular
algorithm National policy gradient uh
the many other algorithms uh uh that go
by policy gradient uh under that go
under policy gradient umbrella and
there's also a lot of uh prior work on
approximate policy attrition especially
in the OR community so I'm not I'm not
at all being exhausted I'm not even
trying
any questions so far
yes
ah two
we did do some simulations we saw that
even without regularization it's uh it's
doing fine it's converging we saw the
geometric conventions but we haven't
actually compared it uh with the case of
regularization
yes
yes policy iteration actually uh has not
just linear convergence it's finite
convergence after there's a finite
number of steps after that it found
three five topics
yes yes
so why I should not take infinite steps
your quality is different that breaks
down later so at this point
compared to policy iteration which
establishes the finite step this looks
like a step back but everything falls in
place when we go to activated the final
thing
four questions
oh cool so
um in reinforcement run everything I
talked about so far is called tabular
setting because I'm working with the
full State space action space in essay
dimensional space and that's a very high
dimensional space in reality people like
to approximate it by lower dimensional
space so essentially what you do is my Q
function is an essay dimensional Vector
essay is huge I come up with B feature
vectors my fees are feature vectors each
one is the essay dimensional Vector I
have B of them and I basically live in
this lower dimensional Subspace I
approximate my Q function by a linear
combination of these D vectors and I
want to find the best possible
approximation and my policy policy is a
function of state and action as well for
each state for each action what
probability should I take that action
with so that also is an essay
dimensional object and I want to
approximate that as well and what I what
I'm doing here is that I'm using the
same feature with this to represent both
Q function to approximate both Q
function and the policy uh and this is
the right linear function approximation
in the setting and notice that let's
first fix a policy Pi the corresponding
Q function Q Pi may not lie in the
Subspace it's living somewhere outside
so I can't even find Q Pi if I if I want
to work only in the Subspace and then
what I would do is uh so even though at
this point I haven't even still got into
the critic sampling from data but uh but
still because I only work with lower
dimensional objects even the genie
critique cannot give me essay
dimensional Vector so I have to
approximate this Q Pi by something and
um uh what we use is projectable
equation we did not introduce this this
is well known from uh from the late 90s
but uh I believe this was not used in
the actor critics setting before our
work so the idea is that suppose you
have the corresponding Bellman equation
earlier I had Q by equal to H Pi of Q Pi
now I introduced the projection step
which means the the fixed point I'm
trying to find is I want to find a q
tilde in the Subspace such that if I
apply H Pi it goes outside the space I
can't it can possibly go outside the
space I can't help it but if I project
it back then I come back to the space
so this is some kind of approximation of
of the real coupon
uh so now let's say that um this is what
I do so instead of working with Q Pi K
uh exact Q by K I work with this lower
dimensional approximations for both Pi K
and uh Q by K if I were to do that this
update equation becomes very simple it's
just this equation now Pi is represented
by this Phi times Theta so instead of
working with pi K plus 1 I'll work with
Theta K plus 1 because Theta is a d
Dimension Vector so uh Theta K plus 1 is
simply going to be Theta K plus beta K
times W by K
uh and uh
um and this wpk is the solution of the
projected value equation
so now what is going to happen so
because I'm doing these projections at
every step I'm actually going to incur
some errors there's nothing I can do
about it and this theorem the first two
terms are same as before so now again
I'm looking at the policy at the end of
K iterations I'm looking at the
corresponding error and uh this is
geometrically converging but it's not
converging to zero the error goes to
this terms go to zero but now I have
introduced a constant error and what is
e approx it's basically whenever I
project from this high dimensional space
to the lower dimensional space the error
I am introducing the maximum value of
that is this e approx this is the
approximation error due to
um uh due to function approximation in
some sense it's inevitable to have this
uh even in the policy evaluation problem
but now when you put it all together
within the npg framework what we are
saying is that we end up with a blow up
factor of this gamma over 1 minus gamma
whole square and turns out that for this
approximate policy iteration class of
algorithms this blow up factor is in
inevitable in the sense that this an
example presented by vertical since
syclist in their book which shows that
this is inevitable for any API algorithm
any questions on this
yes
you have the approximation error for the
Q function that's the approximation for
the for the policy
um not quite it doesn't come up directly
but uh I'm using the same feature
vectors for both policy and queue so in
some sense that is taken care of plus
one way of thinking about it unless
you're thinking about it is that this
approximate patient can be thought of as
a maximum possible approximation in the
policy evaluation even that statement is
not quite correct uh because physicalist
and Android introduce the projected
primary equation they show that the
approximation error they get is this
times one over one minus gamma and what
I am because I'm taking back machinery
and putting it within the activated
framework and getting another one of our
government's gamma Factor
IAL policy does not share the same
feature
uh yeah actually that's a good question
uh this is again something that goes
back to Sham carpeting
um so writing a clean update if you work
with different feature vectors in both
spaces is going to be messy the way uh
it's presented in the original paper is
that you should have a compatible
function approximation representation
the representation you use here and you
use the one you use here should be
somehow related if you are working with
policy gradient that relation is not uh
not identical identity relation but in
our national policy gradient the
relation is that they're the same
feature that's another nice thing about
National policy again but if you don't
do that I think everything breaks down
pretty much even the algorithm will not
start making sense
congratulations
sure sure that's another way of saying I
mean that satisfies this assumption good
that's it that's a good observation
oh cool so so far I talked about actor
alone a genie was giving us the value
functions in the tabular and the
function approximation setting now I
want to attack the question of how do
you find this value function so I'll
directly work in the function
approximation linear function
approximation setting and recall that I
want to solve this projected belman
equation and since I am living in the
lower dimensional space my Q Pi can be
approximated by Phi times W pi and uh uh
due to linearity so everything here the
the Bellman policy evaluation operator
is linear and the projection also turns
out to be linear so you can show that
this equation is essentially a linear
equation of this form I'm not showing
what this A and B are A and B depend on
the policy on the Bellman operator on
the feature vectors everything but
essentially it's a linear equation of
this form and the only problem is that
since they depend on the underlying
model I don't know this A and B if a new
A and B I could just invert it yes and
just to
we agree that a it is not necessarily
invertible or full rank especially
because of the protection right
uh turns out that it is full rank
actually because
um
I mean you go from essay Dimensions to D
dimension in fact it can be shown that a
is all its eigenvalues are negative D is
less than S A so it will be invertible
so if you want you can invert it but the
only reason I can't invert it is because
I don't know a
the projection
wild in the space
are linearly independent
I mean I'm not solving a essay
dimensional thing my w is a d
dimensional object
originally I was in essay Dimensions
which is big from million Dimensions I
project two D Dimensions 10 Dimensions
okay so so it's not surprising that it's
um
so when we have noisy access to a and b
which means that every time I can sample
uh a copy of a and a copy of B but I'm
getting noisy samples moreover turns out
okay turns out that what we have are
markavian markavian samples so
uh so it turns out that the right way of
solving this is using stochastic
approximation so essentially I'm doing w
k plus 1 equal to Blue K plus my step
size times I'm trying to solve a w minus
b equal to 0 that's exactly what you
wrote here plus noise
so if there is no noise and if step size
is uh uh okay never mind so this is
called stochastic approximation and if
you want to understand more about
stochastic approximation you should
check out my tutorial on Monday because
Sanjay said I had only five I have only
five minutes so I'll just keep going so
uh if I I'm not going to show what A and
B are but if I substitute the right
values of A and B and after massaging it
little bit what I get is the famous TD
temporal difference uh learning
algorithm the whole motivation here is
just to get to temporal difference all
it says is w k plus 1 equal to WK plus
step size times my feature Vector the
all my features I have my D feature
vectors right evaluate them at this
component so I have a policy at each
time I take an action with respect to
the policy I take I look at my current
state and my action that gives me a
triple I value the feature Vector at
that triple and then multiply by this
Delta which is called the temporal
difference and this is simply my current
reward plus gamma times uh ignore this
Gap from the time B plus uh something
that again depends on the the fee of the
samples and this w
now I am interested in not only doing
this policy evaluation I want to do it
in an off policy setting which means I
want to evaluate policy pi and each
iteration of the actor critic my goal
post is changing first I want to order
if I want like Pi 2 then Pi 3 and so on
and uh but I want to keep sampling with
a fixed policy pi b because maybe my
data was collected long time ago using
uh a given policy maybe think of
clinical trials as an example so then
then it turns out the right thing is to
change this algorithm by simply
presenting an important sampling Factor
here which is just the ratio of the
policies
and turns out if I do this it's not
going to work that this account example
from I mean this is a very old count
example but I'm citing the book uh so
what they say is that if you have
function approximation and you are
working in off policy then they'll uh
there is Convergence and that phenomena
is called deadly Triad and what we do is
um uh and the reason for this is because
uh now when I'm doing off policy
sampling the projection I'm doing is
with respect to my sampling policy and
I'm trying to evaluate a Target policy
and these two don't come you I mean
these two are not consistent and the
overall thing is not a contraction so
what we say is that you should use
InStep TD instead of one step TD and
then all that means is that uh
um uh you take uh you take the temporal
differences over the last M steps and
add them up with the corresponding
important sampling ratios and discount
factors and uh this works so putting
everything together I think the quick
takeaway is that if you use InStep TD
Within important sampling that overcomes
deadly Triad in the off policy setting
and that can find the solution of the
projected Billman equation and the rate
of convergence is this W Pi is the
solution of the predictable equation if
I run this inner loop if I learn the
critic for T iterations then the rate of
convergence if I use a constant step
size it's going to be the first term is
geometric so that's not problematic but
the second term is a constant that
depends on my step size if I make my
step size small then this error is going
to be small
so now uh picking the right steps as I
can show a rate of convergence of 1 over
square root of t or sample complexity of
Epsilon power 2. so pretty much my last
slide what I'm going to do now is put
everything together in the actor critic
framework so I have my critic I want to
do actor critic with a linear function
approximation natural actor critic to be
more precise and I'm doing off policy
sampling and in step 3D with importance
importance samplings and I run it for T
iterations and uh within each step of
the actor and then for the actor I am
doing natural proxy gradient with linear
function approximation and I'm running
it for K actor steps so totally I am
using TK samples uh then the theorem
essentially puts everything together so
first the first two terms come from
natural policy gradient in the tabular
setting this was the function
approximation and this is the critic
error and everything together gives a
overall sample complexity of Epsilon
power minus 2 which turns out to be the
optimal rate and I'll stop
thanks
[Applause]
questions